let's bring in cbs news chief washington
correspondent major garrett major joins
us now good morning to you
uh on friday you were here on this show
and you said the white house needs
transparency transparency transparency
instead we got quite a fog over the
weekend is there a strategy here
well essentially to discuss this virus
politically not scientifically that's
what this white house has done from the
beginning it's what it's doing now
remember the bob woodward tapes the
president told bob word
confidentially that he likes to play
this down he's playing it down for his
own care
it's quite obvious that the president's
own predilections his preferences are
driving the orientation of what his
own doctors say about his own care
that's not my assessment that's what the
doctor sean conley said
to reporters yesterday he wants to
reflect the upbeat attitude of the
president
regardless of what his actual condition
is
and no very clear explanation of what
this
quite obvious aggressive treatment
strategy is all about
regeneron rum de severe and
dexamethasone combined as dr ages said
could make a lot of sense if you know
what the underlying conditions are but
it also could be
where the president's saying i want the
most aggressive treatment possible
and you're under my orders so do as i
say we don't know what the truth is
and that creates not only confusion but
uncertainty the president made an
intriguing comment in one of the videos
posted over the weekend he said he'd
gone to covid school real coveted school
the kind of stuff you can't get in a
book
and yet at the same time a senior
campaign official is mocking joe biden
for using
a mask as a quote prop what are those
two diverging statements
tell you about the campaign's posture
toward the virus in these final 29 days
well let me just quote the national
security advisor robert o'brien who told
our colleague margaret brennan yesterday
on face the nation this is a nasty
resilient virus it can get anywhere even
inside the white house even when you're
one of the most protected places on
earth
i think that tells you everything you
need to know about how potent this virus
is
how much the white house when given a
moment's candor can express that
jason miller is talking politics again
as they frequently do
not science yeah major every day in this
country people die without being able to
say goodbye to their loved ones and yet
we saw the president say hello to his
campaign supporters yesterday
while suffering from coronavirus i'm
sure the the supporters enjoyed that
will the voters more broadly appreciate
the president breaking protocol
this is a break of quarantine it could
endanger secret service agents but for
trump supporters
it is a reflection of the president's
willingness
and his imperative to go see them and
acknowledge them they want to be
acknowledged in whatever condition the
president might be
that acknowledgement will for them be
reassuring
and motivating even though
scientifically and medically
it raises a great number of questions
can't hold your breath and drive an suv
at the same time major thank you very
much